Mmm.
Which was actually spread by rats!
What?
People actually used to believe they were spread by bees.
So what they had to do was develop a potion to cure the minks of the black plague.
We're spreading it around, because as we know, minks were everywhere back in the Middle Times.
So what we had to do was create this mink juice elixir.
Mink juice elixir, very good.
Now, what we found out though was that it doesn't work on minks.
However, it has incredible healing properties for humans.
You feel lighter, you feel happier, you feel closer to Jesus, or further away, honestly, whichever one you want.
You get what you want.
Fascinating.
Oh, me first?